after our warmup we can now come to the
real problem we have again a random
variable theta with a known prior
distribution and we're interested in a
point estimate what will be different
this time however is that we now have an
observation and we also have a model of
that observation as a conditional
distribution given the value of the true
parameter we observe a value of that
random variable that values little X and
on the basis of that value we would like
to now come up with a point estimate of
the unknown random variable theta how do
we proceed we can of course use the
Bayes rule and the Bayes rule is going
to give us a distribution for the
unknown random variable given the
observation that we have obtained and
that distribution could be discrete or
continuous let me just plot something as
if it's continuous and now that we have
the posterior distribution of theta we
would like to come up with a point
estimate how do we do it remember our
earlier conclusion if we do not have any
observations if we live in a universe
where we have a distribution of theta
and we want a point estimate the optimal
one the one that minimizes the mean
squared error is the expected value of
our random variable but now we live in a
different universe in a universe where
we have a conditional distribution of
theta we want to minimize the
conditional mean squared error because
this is the mean squared error that
applies to this conditional universe in
which we have obtained a particular
observation what is going to be the
result of this minimization well this is
a problem that's identical to the
problem of minimizing this quantity
except that now this problem is posed in
a conditional universe so we just follow
the same steps and obtain the same
solution the solution is going to be the
expected value of the unknown random
variable except that now we live in a
conditional universe and therefore we
should take the relevant expected value
which is the conditional expectation
given the information that we have
available in our hands so to summarize
what we obtain is that the optimal
estimate is the conditional expectation
and this is a relation between numbers
but if we want to think about it more
abstractly we have designed an estimator
which is based on a random variable
capital X and calculates the expected
value of our random variable that we're
trying to estimate namely theta on the
basis of X let us now continue with some
observations remember that the expected
value of theta minimizes this quantity
and we can write this more explicitly in
terms of the following inequality that
if we use the expected value as an
estimate the resulting mean squared
error is less than or equal to the mean
squared error that we would have
obtained if we had used any other
estimate see so this is a relation
that's true for all see now let us take
this inequality and translate it into
our more interesting context where we
have an observation available once more
the conditional expectation minimizes
the mean squared error let us write out
explicitly what this means in a form
analogous to what we wrote down earlier
what it means is that the expected value
of theta minus the estimate namely the
conditional expectation squared in this
conditional universe in which we live
this is less than or equal to the mean
squared error that we would have
obtained if we had used any other
estimate
in the place of the conditional
expectation so for any value G of X that
we might have used the error would have
been at least as large why am I using
this notation G here let us go back to
the bigger picture what we have is that
we are obtaining a numerical value X we
do some processing to it which
corresponds to some function G and we
come up with an estimate which is a
function of the little X that we have
observed so no matter what estimate we
use the mean squared error is going to
be at least as large as the mean squared
error that we obtain if we use the
conditional expectation now let us take
this inequality here and write it in a
more abstract form suppose that we have
settled on some particular estimator and
we want to compare this estimator with
the expected value estimator then we are
going to get the following inequality if
we use the conditional expectation as an
estimator in a conditional universe
where we know the value of the random
variable X the corresponding mean
squared error is going to be less than
or equal to the mean squared error
obtained by the alternative estimator G
what does this inequality say this
inequality is simply an abstract version
of the previous inequality the previous
inequality is true for all little X here
we have an inequality between random
variables this random variable here is
the random variable that takes this
specific numerical value whenever
capital X takes the value little X when
X takes the value little X were
auditioning on this event and when X is
equal to little X this quantity takes on
this particular numerical value and
similarly on the other side this is a
random variable that takes this
particular numerical value whenever
capital X is equal to little X now that
we have an inequality between random
variables actually between conditional
expectations we can take expectations of
both sides and we use the law of
iterated expectations the expectation of
a conditional expectation is an
unconditional expectation so we obtain
this as the expected value of this
quantity and it's less than or equal to
the expected value of this quantity
using again the law of iterated
expectations we obtain this relation
here and what this inequality is saying
is that the overall mean squared error
if we use the conditional expectation
now as an estimator is less than or
equal to the mean squared error that we
would obtain if we had used any other
estimator so this inequality refers to
the following picture we obtain an
observation which is a random variable
we process that random variable to come
up with an estimator which is a function
of the random variable that we observe
and so is itself a random variable so
when we use this random variable to
estimate theta we obtain a certain mean
squared error this is going to be at
least as large as the mean squared error
that we obtain if we use the conditional
expectation as our estimator
so to summarize the conditional
expectation of theta viewed as a random
variable
as an estimator what we call the LMS
estimator of theta has the property that
it minimizes the mean squared error over
all possible alternative estimators so
if you want to design this box using
some other function G you're going to
obtain a mean squared error that's going
to be no better than what you obtain if
you were to use the conditional
expectation